President Trump is halfway through his
stay at his private resort in Florida
he's been keeping tabs on Washington
getting in a Twitter spat with House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi as she holds on to
those articles of impeachment
correspondent Richard sand is down in
West Palm Beach following the president
where mr. Trump is targeting a familiar
foe
good evening rich now good evening Mike
and president Trump says speaker Pelosi
should focus on homelessness in
California as the president is about at
the midway point of two weeks here in
Florida he has an uncertain impeachment
future ahead speaker Pelosi says after
weeks of hearings and impeachment
testimony quote the facts are clear and
every witness told the same story
despite the president's attempts to
cover it up president Trump abused his
power for his own personal gain
hashtag defend our democracy the impasse
is unbroken
speaker Pelosi still has not said she
will send to the Senate the articles of
impeachment the House passed before
journeying for winter recess by
withholding them from the Senate she's
leaving in limbo when or if a Senate
trial will begin
she says she's delaying a trial to
compel Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell to allow for witness testimony
Democrats say the White House is
stonewalling and if the president and
administration officials did nothing
wrong in suspending aid to Ukraine they
should have no problem testifying about
it it would be unprecedented for the
United States Senate in an impeachment
trial to Anna that will decide on
whether the president is convicted and
removed from office to not hear any
witnesses Andrew Johnson's impeachment
41 witnesses President Clinton's
impeachment three witnesses Republicans
say the speaker and House Democrats
rushed to impeach the president and that
their delay tactic is the latest proof
that this is a political charade she's
currently holding a live grenade they
have pulled the pin out in impeachment
she's gotten in her hand and she frankly
doesn't know what to do with it there
are not two-thirds of the Senators
willing to convict and remove the
president and as a consequence and in an
election year for crying out loud so as
a consequence we all know how this ends
yesterday President Trump complained
that impeachment was a distraction
making dealing with foreign leaders more
difficult today another foreign policy
dispute emerged a spokesman for
Philippine president Rodrigo
Duterte says he will formally decline an
invitation to visit the United States
Duterte is protesting a provision in a
congressional spending bill that
sanctions philippine officials for
detaining a government critic there the
country is banning two US senators dick
Durbin and Patrick Leahy from traveling
to the Philippines the Philippine
government also says it could require
Americans to obtain a visa to travel to
the Philippines making it more difficult
for Americans to visit Mike Richardson
live in West Palm Beach rich thanks a
lot